wie wordt dan de lijsttrekker
ja die vraag gaan we beantwoorden
nadat de leden hebben besloten
of er 1 lijst komt of niet
er is vast al overlegd toch
nee daar gaan we over besluiten als er 1 lijst is
eerst moeten de leden kiezen of er 1 lijst komt
zou je het zelf willen
daar GA ik niks over zeggen
ik GA op geen enkele naam in
je kunt wel zeggen of u het wilt toch
alles kan maar ik GA het niet doen
ik kan me niet voorstellen dat u het niet wilt
ik GA er niks over zeggen
ik sprak net 1 lid van de PvdA en die zei
ik zou wel graag meneer klaver als lijsttrekker willen
dat is heel aardig maar ik kan er niks over zeggen
zou u zich gepasseerd voelen als u niet zou worden
ik GA er niks over zeggen